à à
anh alo
mọi người nghe thấy không nhỉ Mọi người
thấy màn hình mình nhỉ
Ừ ok không Sao thấy màn hình rồi nhưng
không biết mọi người nghe rõ alo
anh
tên gì chào các bạn
ừ ừ
Chúc các bạn nghe rõ nhỉ
à à
Vì sao tự nhiên vừa rồi Mười ông so với
cùng còn Năm Ông này
buổi cuối và nhé em
ờ ờ
a Galaxy mình mới xem lại thì công nhận
là đúng với bất ngờ Thật
Ừ chứ không phải là mình à không Chỗ
mình không mưa gì cả à
anh nói bị già bị rè ra mà bạn vào mưa
vậy
Ừ thì đấy thì à mình cũng bất ngờ chứ
không phải mình cố tình làm các bạn bất
ngờ đó là mình chỉ nhận ra đây là buổi
quấy rồi à bột cuối của cơ bản thôi
Ừ
thì chắc là
Xin chào mình hôm nay mình có mình Mình
có ghi cụ thể đây này
Ừ thế để đầu tiên là tại sao tự nhiên
mình có Đề cập về cái vụ 222 câu hỏi
cuối này thông báo với lộ trình cụ thể
ở đây
Ừ Tự nhiên bây giờ mình mới thấy da mình
có thông báo ở video như video đầu tiên
gì vậy
từ buổi đầu tiên mình đã nói qua lý do
mình học cái ngày này kết hợp việc là là
nói chung là để làm gì và và áp dụng ở
đâu đấy
nhưng mà
Ừ hôm qua
Ừ cái này mình trao đổi trước với các
bạn trai kiểu gì anh Toàn sẽ lên với bài
đang cụ thể sau đó hôm qua mình còn nói
chuyện với ép shop Mẹ từng nói với cái
vụ là hình như mình có từng từng nói rồi
đó là hết shop và FPT Software
nhà tài trợ định này trội cho bên trường
mình
à vì cái à học bổng cũng như là Trung ạ
đạp đổi ra các thứ thứ nếu mà các bạn
theo ngày này đúng không Thì
à Hôm nay mình có bàn lại với với một
người
Kiều và người đấy bảo là
Ừ mình không đăng một cái gì đó cụ thê
lên để cho các bạn học
Mẹ Maria
bọn mình thì dạy các bạn với hết sức với
cái tâm của mình và nhiệt huyết các thứ
thứ đi
kèm theo cả kiến thức nữa chứ không phải
Không Khí Đức nhưng mà lại chưa Lên hẳn
một cái gì đó rất là cụ thể Nên là các
bạn thì ra nhiều bạn vẫn còn mông lung
các bạn vẫn là
khoa học thực sự học theo kiểu là ở thấy
đi học
anh thấy đi học hơn là kiểu là các bạn
thực sự là biết được là mình đang học để
làm gì
em có bạn thì đang học theo ngành Công
nghệ thông tin thì ừ thì đương nhiên là
thầy có lợi cho các bạn nhưng có bạn thì
không thấy rõ điều đấy
cho nên là
xe mình nghĩa mình vẫn sẽ đăng lại bài
Tia hơi muộn vì hôm nay bụi cuối rồi mới
bắt đầu đăng là cụ thể là từng khóa học
một mình sẽ học những cái gì trong cửa
khóa học đấy có tầm bao nhiêu buổi là
như mình đã từng nói là cái việc buổi
mình phải ước lượng bởi vì là nhỡ đâu
hôm nào đó mình dậy thấy kích thước đấy
các bạn bò khó quá mình lại phải chia
nhỏ buổi gian nữa vân vân kiểu bị chạy
giáo án a bị cháy giáo án đấy con vân
vân nên không thể chắc chắn được với
đúng số buồn
ừ ừ
Ừ nếu em mình nghĩ là phải có một cái gì
đó thực sự là rất là cụ thể đang cho các
bạn để các bạn hình dung được
và đương nhiên là như mình từng nói đó
là các bạn học cái này thì sản công thừa
nhưng mà các bạn vẫn còn mông lung mình
nghĩ là vẫn có điều đấy nên là mình sẽ
đang làm Lần Nữa
anh hoặc là để cho những bạn mà chưa học
thì khóa của mình bởi vì ạ Thế Mong lâu
quá không họ chẳng ngại thì các bạn đọc
qua các bạn sẽ thấy à Cái này
họ cảm thấy là phù hợp họ sẵn sang tốn
thời gian hãy dùng từ tốn thời gian để
mà tìm hiểu về nó
anh Bởi vì các bạn
anh mất thời gian để mà ngồi nghe Mình
chém gió hay gì đó về chia sẻ đúng không
Mình cũng mất thời gian
cho các bạn thì chúng ta phải đạt được
ít nhất một cái gì đó đúng không ạ
A và ờ ờ vụ ép xốp thì mình có nói đó là
thì mình chắc là sẽ có những cái hộp màu
và
kiểu khuyến khích các bạn học tập cũng
như là
tạo cơ hội cho các bạn nếu mà các bạn
theo ngày này có thể làm bên đấy Bên
mình sẽ làm triển khai vụ đấy
Nên
mình nghĩ là
sẽ có lợi cho các bạn khá là nhiều thứ
nhất là hôm qua mình có nói chuyện với
bên đấy thì bên đấy bảo là kiểu tài trợ
cho bên mình ấy thì bên mình luôn theo
tiêu chí là làm vì cộng đồng thế nên là
không phải vì nhóm không phải vì yêu tim
hai cái gì cả đấy nhưng trái tim thì làm
cái này sẽ được danh tiếng là chủ yếu
thôi chứ không thu lại được một cái gì À
tất cả mọi thứ đều trên tinh thần tự
nguyện miễn phí nhưng phải có trách
nhiệm em phải có nói chung à
anh không thể là vì dạy các bạn theo
kiểu là
ạ bây đây là hướng lên mổ lên Xong hình
lên dẹp và mình sẽ bọn mình sẽ đảm bảo
trách nhiệm rất là nghiêm túc trong
những cái vấn đề này ví dụ là kiến thức
bắt buộc phải chính xác
A và
300 Nói chuyện là có thầy cô lên lịch
xong rồi bỏ bỏ lịch bỏ tiết hơn lên vì
một lý do gì đấy
ừ ừ
ở tại đấy mình mình
mở đầu video này mày nói qua những cái
đấy Thực ra là cái này đáng lẽ phải đến
nói ở cuối gieo hoặc và đăng một bài cụ
thể tý gì kiểu gì mình sẽ đăng bây giờ
mình đang nói trước các bạn làm như thế
nhé
bộ phim
à à
Ờ Ờ nói chung thì
à tiện thể về cái vụ đấy thì
em có cái cái bạn mà chiều chiều nay anh
còn nói chuyện mình bảo là tớ thế cái từ
trước ngày nay anh không lên giáo án dậy
à hay là có không có giáo trình gì á hai
anh ôm giờ chị GB nữa
thị trường Hồi trước anh dạy về à
Ẩm Thực sự thì mình muốn vạch làm cái lộ
trình lộ trình thôi nhưng mình không có
giáo án 2 giáo trình cụ thể
khi tỉnh dậy nó bởi vì à Mình đang dạy
theo hơi bị Theo kinh nghiệm một tí mình
cảm thấy cái gì đang phù hợp với cái lớp
này thì mình sẽ dạy
bộ phim Chứ thực sự thì không có hạt một
cái giáo giáo trình dịch cả
Ừ nhưng mình vẫn từng làm soạn các tài
liệu các được rồi nên các bạn yên tâm về
việc là mình không phải là miếng lười
hay là mình không có kinh nghiệm làm
việc đấy em
em về à Nói chung là hôm nay thì chắc
vẫn chắc rằng vẫn sẽ ra buổi cuối của
cái lớp atwell cơ bản này để các bạn
hình dung qua về equil các thứ thứ Bạn
biết cách các thứ
A và chỉ là tí mình sẽ chỉ cho các bạn
việc kiến thức các bạn đang áp dụng như
mình đã từng nói wow nó áp dụng được cho
cả những bạn làm bên kế toán hay cái gì
đó làm việc với excel nhiều thì các bạn
sẽ thấy à thế này nó rất giống với excel
làm việc hôm nay mình họp với nối bàn
chẳng hạn đúng không cái nổi bảng các từ
từ nhau thì tí mình cũng sẽ chỉ có bạn
với excel nó có giống hệt
ở các câu lệnh các thứ thứ thì các bạn
sẽ thấy à Cái này mình em giúp được mình
học không phải mình học xong cái khóa cơ
bản này mình đã đủ làm một cái gì đó rồi
chứ không phải là cần học thêm cái gì
nữa
ờ ờ
à mình mình chắc à trưa đến giờ học thì
mình tranh thủ trả lời
đầu tiên thì có bạn kia nói về dạy FBI
chuyên sâu thư gan tế mà mình khi mình
đi dạy học đấy Mình thích dậy nhất chính
là skul này nên là mình nghĩ là mình
cũng sẽ dạy các bạn không hẳn là
Ừ cái việc chuyên sâu ấy thì mình sẽ
dùng từ đây là
anh nói giống trợ feoh2 Nó là kiểu Apple
cái cái trên đường link của mình có cho
bạn xem là
điều gì sushi này learn SQL này
Ừ cái đường link này không biết được Các
bạn có biết chưa ạ
ẩm thực ra mình luôn để link ở phần mô
tả của các video rồi nhưng mà để mình
gửi lại các bạn như thế thì cái link này
bị sao vậy
I cling này nó đã đề cập tất cả những
cái từ cái bên tap thứ ba này là những
cái mà cái môn skul đã có mấy Hai sẽ học
cái này là áp dụng khá là
Ừ nó nó nó là chuyên sâu đấy Nó là kiểu
dạng mà hiểu rõ hơn về các cơ chế Mở
rộng hơn của Apple có thể làm được những
gì nữa Nhưng cái này vẫn chị đã
anh vẫn chỉ là lý thuyết
à Còn bà đẻ có bạn hiểu hơn về quy ai
chứ em chưa chắc các bạn áp dụng vào đi
làm phải nói thẳng như thế bởi vì à Toàn
bộ những cái này khi mình đang đi làm
thực tế này mình em giúp đúng mỗi cái
cái cái đầu tiên là ký nick này
Ừ nhưng mà những kiến thức này thì đúng
là áp dụng đi làm thì các bạn sẽ hiểu
hiểu hiểu hơn là nhà nó có tồn tại và là
nó chạy cơ chế hoạt động của nó như thế
em còn về việc dạy cho các bạn esquare
để mà các bạn đi làm rồi Các bạn cần
chuyên sâu hơn ví dụ là những câu nâng
cao cực kỳ nâng cao
thì mình sẽ dùng từ nâng cao chứ không
phải chuyên sâu nữa
Hì hì à
thì mình nghĩ là
mình chỉ dạy được một mức tương đối bởi
vì mình cũng chưa trải nghiệm được nhiều
cũng như là
ờ ờ
em có người giỏi hơn mình ở trong cái
mạng đấy bởi vì a mình thực sự thì mình
không chuyên không chuyên những cái đấy
anh
không chuẩn bằng được mấy bạn kia được
bởi vì à mình à theo cái bên skul này
Thực tế là mình à
áo kiểu gần đây đi làm mình mới đọc mà
nhiều chứ hồi đấy mình bảo mình mới nghỉ
dậy được tầm nửa năm thôi mình mới đi
làm ở bên ngoài nửa năm còn trước đấy
thì mình toàn chủ yếu tự học đàn gà ở
học mấy cái lý thuyết về axwell này để
mà đi dạy sàn dậy thì là khi mình đi
giảng dậy thì các bạn chỉ cần biết
chuyên sâu mà các bạn áp dụng thực tế ít
lắm ý
khoa học Apple cơ bản cần học thêm gì
nữa để đi thực tập
à thực ra thì mình đã từng nói từ video
đầu tiên đó là các bạn học xong khóa này
thận chứa học cả ép cao chuyên sâu xong
các bạn vẫn cần phải có kiến thức thực
tế làm được những câu truy vấn phức tạp
thì các bạn mới có thể đi làm được nhưng
mình cứ nói là những câu ép cao nâng cao
chứ theo cái ngày này theo đặc biệt là
mình đã từng nói ngay từ video đầu cho
bà không để ý đó theo ngành này thì
lương rất là ngon ngon hơn cả lập trình
viên bình thường nó để lên đến 5000 đô
cơ mà thì chả loa không có chuyện là các
bạn thực tập cho vui Được cái bên mạng
SQL và người ta không tuyển nữa vui được
em ra đòi hỏi người có kinh nghiệm rồi
thế này là mình không nói về vụ là các
bạn dùng cái Apple cơ bản hay là chuyên
sâu để mới đi tập được và các bạn chỉ áp
dụng cho các bạn nhảy sang ngôn ngữ lập
trình thì các bạn áp dụng được thôi
ừ ừ
Ừ chắc là tuần sau mình sẽ
à mình mình tí mình sẽ đăng bài cụ thể
các bạn về để trình học sắp tới đối
ngoại sẽ bao gồm tuần sau sẽ các tuần
sau sẽ học cái gì chất chia nhỏ ra một
tí cho các bạn đỡ cảm thấy quá tải
à à
à Còn cái vụ FeS in sâu phải thực sự thì
em mình
Anh cũng đang kiểu đang rất có hướng dẫn
Ừ nhưng mà theo theo như mầm hồi mình mà
mình dậy ở trên lớp đi thì em yêu cơ bản
này xong này sau đó đi đến đó
có một tí về phân lân với giao diện và
nhảy sang ngôn ngữ lập trình php
ạ sau đó thì sao cái pp
ạ sau Cài file thì mình sẽ kết hợp với P
với F Word và comment để làm ra được một
trang web cơ bản và mình sẽ dạy các bạn
làm trắng không những người trong cách
cơ bản mà Làm hẳn một trang web kiểu nó
là gần như một sản phẩm một cái đồ án để
các bạn hoàn toàn thể hình dung được một
cái trang web ví dụ là một trang web bán
hàng hay trong các tin tức thì nó sẽ
hoạt động như thế nào Tại hồi mình dạy
học và như thế
A và xử lý bài toán thực tế nó là như
thế nào từ việc thiết kế cơ sở dữ liệu
vẽ mô hình
khi quan hệ cũng như là phân tích Chức
năng phân tích xem mà trang web về thực
sự cần gì Khách hàng cần cái gì Vân vân
vân vân mình sẽ hướng dẫn tất cả những
cái điều đấy
em thậm chí là hồi mà mình dậy ở trường
đó là mình còn bắt bên bên nhưng trường
mình là có à
có ba cái đồ án tốt nghiệp nó khác với
trường đại học chính quy một tí
từ
ngày 3 đồ án sông áo kiểu năm nhất thì
bọn mình học à
ý kiến thức kiểu ở hàn lâm kiểu la la
giống trường đại học chính quy có 52 bọn
mình học xanh chuyên ngành và bọn mình
có giận hai cái đồ án tốt nghiệp vào năm
thứ hai rồi nghĩa là bọn mình họp xong
cái pp đấy thì mình sẽ bọn mình sẽ
làm luôn hằng cái đoán là một trang web
đó đúng không Mà trang web cơ bản và
cũng làm à
anh cũng phải thuyết trình bảo vệ trước
Hội đồng các thầy cô bên lập trình cũng
như là đôi khi sẽ mời cả các người ở bên
ngoài giống như các nhà Tuyển dụng về
các người công ty khác về để xem có thể
tuyển dụng luôn đấy mà bạn đấy bảo vệ
rất là ổn rất tốt và có năng lực vân vân
vân đấy thì cái việc đấy khiến cho sinh
viên của trường mình nói chung ấy biết
cách thuyết trình biết cách để có làm từ
a đến z một cái sản phẩm hoàn thiện và
nói chung là khiến cho kĩ năng của sinh
viên trường mình thấy khá là khá là ổn
tự tin bởi vì
anh Bởi vì đến a học kì 2 lại làm thêm
một cái đùa nữa Nói chung nhà mới đấy là
chuẩn lịch là bảo vệ xong thì nghỉ Tết
nghỉ tết xong ra học TP nâng cao nasware
nâng cao sau đó thì nhảy sang một card
word à mà level Lập Trung Quốc rất nổi
tiếng và sử dụng rộng rãi của PT sau đó
lại làm cái đồ án chuyên sâu Làm hẳn một
trang web chuyên sâu
Ê về bài toán xử lý hạt một bài toán
nghiệp vụ chứ không phải một trong nước
cơ bản nữa và đương nhiên là nói chung
là đồ ăn hay đấy một đoàn rất là khắc
nghiệt để cho các bạn đấy làm xong đồ án
2 thì các bạn để đi được tập được luôn
rồi đó là mục tiêu hướng từ trước đến
nay ở bên trường mình
bên nhiên là cái đấy nó hơi bị quá tải
hại so với bạn nào mà không hoàn hảo
theo ngày này không theo đường này này
nhưng mà
đi theo mình thì chính vì những cảnh như
thế nó cũng gần như là quyết định sớm
cho các bạn xem à các bạn theo được này
nè không lấy cách làm của trường mình
hồi đấy là như thế thì nên là à chúng
mình tỷ lệ đi làm cũng rất là cao và nói
chung là kiểu các bạn xác định ngay từ
52 rồi mà các bạn nó quyết định được cả
các bạn theo ngày ngày được hay không
rồi khác và nhờ bạn lên đại học chính
quy mình mình phải nhấn mạnh vụ đấy Ở
đây bởi vì có rất nhiều bạn học đại học
chính quy năm 354 mới là họ chuyên ngành
sau 54 bao giờ đi được tập trong tình
trạng mông lung nên thành ra là các bạn
đấy đi tập trong tình trạng nữa vui và
các bạn không biết sẽ làm gì phải làm gì
mà các bạn đấy học kiến thức ở trên lớp
xong thì các bạn để chưa tự mình làm một
cái sản phẩm gì đó để mà khoe với nhà
tuyển dụng cho tất cả mọi thứ đều rất là
mông lung tung nên là tỷ lệ đi làm của
các trường đại học khẳng định là thoát
hơn bên chúng mình trưởng mình là trường
nghề như một phần là dạy cái bể mà ra
làm nghề thì nó cũng cũng được nhưng mà
cái mà mình nhấn mạnh ở đây đó là trường
mình là trường Không hề nổi
lượng sinh viên vào thì ra là nói thẳng
thì trượt trượt trường đại học nên mới
vào bởi vì nó là trường Cao đẳng Cần như
trường cả ngày ấy thành ra là
thành ra là kiểu
cho mấy bạn đấy thực sự là không hẳn là
giỏi như là các bạn ở đại học chính quy
Ừ nhưng mà tỷ lệ đi làm vẫn rất cao thì
thế nên là mình mới áp dụng cách này áp
dụng phương pháp này để đang dạy các bạn
Vì mình thấy à sự thì nó làm cái gì đó
chọn lọc và hiệu quả cho các bạn theo
kiểu là
các bạn hoàn toàn có thể hình dung được
là các bạn phù hợp với ngành nghề này
không
và nó hình dung được là các bạn sẽ phải
làm những cái gì làm ra sản phẩm gì
Ý mình nói hơi quá thời xa mất rồi nhưng
mà chắc là nãy giờ các bạn đang nghe gì
Các bạn cũng hài lòng đúng không hài
lòng với dược à
à mình mình nói qua về cái lộ trình các
thứ Thử như thế kiểu gì bây giờ cũng hơi
muộn là nghe buổi đầu nói mấy cái điều
đấy chung là buổi cuối
mẹ con nói chung là bây giờ thị ạ Mình
ờ ờ
Chào các bạn mình mình có đọc đang đọc
câu hỏi các bạn và thực sự thì các bạn
chịu khó tìm kiếm ngay trên trang cá
nhân của mình Mình có để công khai mình
có điều đấy rồi nên mình mình không tiện
trả lời hết tất cả những cái câu hỏi ví
dụ là
tên trường của anh là gì Vân vân ở đây
ở đâu ạ ạ
cho một khối xúc động Tôi cũng đang run
run chuẩn bị lại mặc áo tiếp vậy
Để mình trả lời nhanh qua các câu hỏi
của các bạn sau nó vào bài nhé
ở buổi tối hôm nay gọi là buổi cuối
nhưng mình cũng sẽ không cố ý kéo dài
thời gian câu giờ các bạn để ông ạ
đề nghị kiểu gì mà đang là cuối tuần này
đúng không ạ
ờ ờ
chỉ cách học tiếng Anh chuyên ngành
ở đây
Cho mình xin phép trả lời câu này nó ra
nào giống như là mà giáo sư Cù Trọng
Xoay một tí đó la mình thích trả lời một
cái câu theo hướng nó chiều sâu một tí
chứ không phải trả lời cụt lủn
Ờ mà trả lời ngay được mạng mình thích
trả lời ấy thì à
Ừ cái này mình xin phép trả lời rộng hơn
đó cách học về công nghệ thông tin với ạ
Tại sao vì
ừ ừ
anh cái ảnh cái này này Nó kiểu nó rất
là mông lung Lúc đầu Lúc đầu nối khi mà
ở nó bị quá tải kiến thức thì tiếng Anh
chuyên ngành nói đúng kiểu thế nó kiểu
toàn từ mới từ cũ thì ít áp dụng mang
tiếng kể cả các bạn IELTS 9.so người này
các bạn Thế là có đây từ không dịch ra
được và đầu tư mới có từ thứ ví dụ điển
hình là cái chích chế cơ này nó là cò
súng này tăng trưởng nó dịch ra là hàng
này hoặc cả tính năng này Ocean views
Thực ra là thủ tục này Villa là
những là kiểu người góc nhìn góc xem nè
đúng không em Intex này là kiểu nó là
chỉ mục này nếu các bạn dịch ra như thế
thì
em không có tác dụng gì cả các bạn phải
giữ nguyên nó thế Nên bài toán ở đây đó
là để học cái tiếng Anh chuyên ngành
cũng như để học Công nghệ gì Nói chung
ấy là các bạn chỉ trong ra là trí nhớ nó
thôi nhớ gặp nó nhiều thì các bạn hình
dung được Man lá xem nó mà dùng để làm
gì
áo kiểu các bạn phải nhớ luôn là dụ bây
giờ Bây giờ bảo công nói lại SQL là gì
Công học MBA có bạn đấy Hôm nay buổi
cuối các bạn biết fyi viết tắt của từ gì
không
cho các bạn dịch ra feoh nó là gì không
các bạn đâu cần quan tâm những điều đấy
đâu Đúng không các bạn vẫn làm được mà
nó ngon
ý nghĩa thực tế bài toán ở đây đó là các
bạn không nên cần phải biết rõ thực sự
bản chất nó là gì đúng không ạ
à à
khi mình còn nốt ở đây liên tục là mỗi
buổi một mẹ nhau tí mình sẽ chia sẻ các
bạn một vài mẹo nhỏ nhé chắc
Ừ chắc là mình có thời gian mình sẽ chia
sẻ
khi đôi khi là khi mình gõ cái gì đó
mình sẽ chỉ các bạn về các phím tắt vậy
cũng rất tiện
các bạn thấy mình gõ nhanh mà ngon tí
mình sẽ chia sẻ các bạn nó việc gõ nó có
thể nhanh là như thế nào không phải
ngoài gọn nhanh mà mình người dùng các
phím tắt để vào nó nhanh ấy đúng không ạ
anh em lớp 12 thì nên tập trung vào thi
đại học rồi mấy cốc à hay là ngược lại ạ
Cái này là tại sao tự nhiên mình phải
nốt lại một cái câu hỏi cùng bạn ở đây
thì mình thấy da có rất nhiều bạn
ở trong như ghi chú school này thậm chữa
bạn đấy Đang còn là cấp 3 chứ không phải
là người đã đi làm cũng như người đang
học đại học gì cả
Ừ thì à Thực tế là học cái này mình thấy
là
à mình mình đầu tiên thì mình cũng không
nên cũng không nên trình mảnh mấy cái
những cái mà mình đang học đánh theo các
tiểu tử Khi mà mình chỉ là học thêm thôi
Và mình thấy nó không bị thừa thế nên là
các bạn cứ học thôi ở đâu nhiên là kiểu
gì về xong sẽ được áp dụng lần nào đấy
đi
à à anh
em thấy trên cái gì đó mình không không
hiểu lắm nhưng mà Ờ đại khái là bạn đấy
Cho ý bạn đấy Đó là tại sao mình không
dùng mấy cái gợi ý để gõ gõ ra nhanh của
axwell mà kiểu mình thường nay gõ Các
bạn thấy là mình mình gõ lại toàn bộ có
lệnh chứ không Mình không dùng tool kéo
thả để mà tạo ra đồng cày datapes cho dù
rõ ràng Cái này hỗ trợ để mà kéo thả ở
ấn chỉ like chuột thôi là tạo được đâu
Tao bai tạm được cột các từ thứ cũng như
là mình không cài thêm một cái mô vài
cái log in để mà mình gõ nhanh hay là để
mà
à Hay là để nó gợi ý cho mình những cái
câu đấy Ở đây
thì mình sẽ phép mình sẽ cắt một tí có
người gọi không hiểu ai gọi
Ok Ok mình sẽ không
Ừ mình không dùng gọi ý Bởi vì mình muốn
kiểu chỉ các bạn gõ từ đầu
mình đấy đấy đấy cũng là một trong những
do mình thương mà qua đó là thậm chứa
mình không soạn bài sẵn mình không soạn
cốt sẵn mà mình sẽ gõ nó đến đâu gõ
đường đầy cho các bạn để các bạn hình
dung được cái tư duy nó đi theo từng
dòng cốt của mình bởi vì mình đã từng
thấy những cái ông thầy soạn sẵn xong
rồi áp dụng những cái đấy cho mọi bụi
dậy của người ta người ta chỉ cần chia
sẻ màn hình Nokia dòng này làm cái này
nha Dạo này làm này nha Dạo này làm này
nhé
thành ra là kiểu nó không nghe tốt em à
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ đấy thì cái cái cậu mạch cảm mạch tư
duy các bạn các bạn học không nên kiểu
bị như thế mà các bạn kéo cũng Nó là
kiểu truyền Từng dòng cốt ngày vào để
mình ghi ngờ nó lại thì mình lên đấy
mình nên cậu nhớ được hơn Đúng rồi Thậm
chứa nhiều lúc mình từng bảo sinh viên
là mình cốt bằng Notepad để mà kiểu nó
không gợi ý một cái gì cả nó không có
màu gì cả để các bạn sẽ phải tự biết
được là các bạn đang có sai đúng để mà
các bạn thuộc dần những cái ấy
Anh Minh vẫn xinh khách không trả lời
một cái câu chưa trả lời Bộ nói cái câu
này
em về mấy cái kiểu các bạn nên mua máy
tính như thế nào mua gì gì gì đó để mà
học tập
ừ ừ
Ừ
mai que thì chắc là mình kiêng mình dậy
đến bếp p để cái nồi để nó cơ sở liệu
thì mình sẽ chạy sang bên Mai quen nha
Nhưng mà thực tế thì à
cho các bạn làm ở đang muốn theo máy
queo thì các bạn hoàn toàn học được cái
kéo này thì các bạn thì câu lệnh nó rất
dùng nó là ép leo câu lệnh nó rất giống
nhau mình từng nói từ đầu rồi
à à
em hiện giờ anh còn chơi game hay không
để dành bao nhiêu thời gian vào ngày
chơi game ờ
thử ca mình không biết mình hiện tượng
nó qua các bạn với cái lộ trình Một Ngày
của mình đó là đôi khi là sẽ dạy xong
rồi ăn xong mọi người cốt mồi luôn Máy
tính nó kiểu hơi bị Hơi bị cá
có cái gì đó không thấy đỡ không tốt lắm
Bởi vì dậy xong cái mình việc đầu tiên
là mình làm à Mình tính em mình ngồi hết
để làm việc rồi ngồi chơi Nói chung mà
mình sinh hoạt trên này nhiều hơn
Ừ thế này ra đây à Nhưng mà chính vì như
thế nên mình quen việc ngồi ngay hơn à à
Ừ cháu nội lúc này ưu điểm gì đó mới gọi
khuyên các bạn nên ngồi như thế nhiều
nhưng mà ý mình là
thì các bạn không quen được có bạn đã
từng nói với mình về một cái vụ đó là
bạn chỉ ngồi được hai tiếng trên máy
tính thì ra thì không tốt các bạn nên
kiểu ngồi lâu hơn mới mất các bạn thực
sự muốn theo ngành Công nghệ thông tin
này đúng không ạ
đi câu sao này tí cho mình cũng chịu
chữa luôn cho các bạn ạ
khi mở cu mình trả lời nốt cái câu này
nhá đi
ờ ờ
ẩm thực tế là mình chưa có cái bằng sư
phạm nào cả nhưng mà trường mình dậy nó
là cao đẳng hàng ra là nó cũng không có
một cái luật lệ nào đó khắc khe để mà
kiểu phải có bằng đại học bằng thạc sĩ
hay bằng sư phạm để mà dậy Ừ nhưng mà Hả
các bạn thấy cách mình dậy thì về cơ bản
thì cũng cũng không đến nỗi khó hiểu
đúng không cũng hiểu được anh hàng ra là
mình cũng tự tin về còn đấy là mình
không bè sinh viên hay các thư từ trước
ngay mình dậy sinh viên thì ạ Cái này
mình hơi khó em tí này là mình dậy sinh
viên tỷ lệ đi làm sinh viên mình rất là
cao kể cả mình đã gặp những người bạn
sinh viên Lúc đầu là không định theo
ngành này nhà mình cũng vui về khi về
xong lôi kéo được rất nhiều bạn đến
chính mình bất ngờ luôn hả bạn em theo
được ngày này
ừ ừ
Ai
có theme bé mình đã trả lời được hết tất
cả câu hỏi rồi đúng không
à à
Ừ Vậy thì hôm là nó ngon mí sẽ phải chữa
bài tập hôm trước nhé
ở tập hôm trước
thì các bạn với mày ý thì bà hôm trước
không có câu hay sao gì cả bởi vì mình
thấy thực ra đây hôm trước các bạn đỡ
bảo vệ mình ra Dạo này anh ra bài đang
đang bị còn rất nhiều việc thành ra hơi
bị quá tải do mình cũng không muốn đặt
mạng các bạn lắm
nhưng mà thầy Mình thấy nhiều bạn cũng
trả lời các giờ hư nó chăm chỉ mình nghĩ
à các bạn đấy Chắc là muốn theo ngày
ngày Họ Xác định theo ngày này Nói chung
là học hành giữa tử tế mình cũng rất vui
vì những cái điều đấy đúng không vui mà
thấy
thì các bạn rồi năng nổ số động mà mình
vui mà nó đi
ở đầu tiên thì ra là có phạm để kỹ gì cơ
Cái bài này chưa có bài hôm trước mình
đã dậy rồi đó là con liên quan những
điểm các thứ mà ngon là qua thêm môn
thôi mình sẽ mình sẽ tạo Hàn quét thấy
bồ à là ta bây để tránh việc lốp cấp
đựng tránh bị trùng tên bạn nó vừa thôi
nhé
buổi quá đi à
Ừ chắc không chụp đâu
à à
ở
đây mình tranh thủ chị các bạn tất cả
phím tắt nhé á
Ừ thứ nhất là để biến tất cả thành Chú
thích vừa rồi Các bạn thấy
Ừ chị ạ Các bạn thức là nếu mà không
biết thì các bạn cho Google thôi nhưng
sao Google thì hơn
anh Bởi vì cái cái này thì phím tắt này
là áp dụng mỗi cho mỗi cái tool này thôi
mình thấy chỗ khác thì thường hay dùng
control control xong rồi dùng cái
dùng control rồi gạch chéo như thế này
ở cái chỗ Hỏi chấm cái chéo ấy thì ra là
nó với mục đích là căn chôn thì chéo chứ
Mày tắm chung nói chậm đâu các bạn để
trên bàn phím của mình không Nó control
hỏi chấm ấy thì bôi bôi bôi đem đoạn đấy
rồi dùng cân cho hỏi chấm điện mình mình
cho các bạn xem một ví dụ nhé á
ờ ờ là sự đây bạn ạ căn chuẩn họ Trần
đấy đấy các bạn biến thế nó đổi màu sẽ
biến anh chú thích tất cả tung khác thì
anh Thế nhưng riêng tu này nó rất là dị
nó có bạn trả lời được rồi nó là căn
chôn ca rồi bấm can xuân ca rồi thêm xe
mà bấm Thanh Sơn kcc thì nào mới biến
anh ấy
ở Thủ Đức ngày nay
cho nên là các bạn nên tra Google cách
tra Google Play nó sẽ là
thường phím tắt thì shop cắt hè thì boss
cái gì đó Comment này sau đó thì SQL
Server đấy nó Jenna thì nó sẽ ra luôn
câu trả lời các bạn kèm chung K + căn
chung C các hướng gì chưa
A và để mà biến nó bỏ chú thích thì lại
ngược lại thôi căng Sơn Ca Con Chung C
nó sẽ ra
ở những cái để mặt tiện hơn giống như là
các bạn thấy đôi khi mình phải bôi đem
cả dòng này để mà trại này đúng không
các bạn sẽ bấm luôn dòng đầu như thế này
thì ra được đấy
anh chàng trai cái chỗ này để bôi đen
luôn cả dòng đấy
Vì sao lò đi ỉa các bạn F5 ở đây cao nó
có gợi ý luôn em Nam để mà chạy luôn à
Tại sao thế à
I
love này Đầu tiên thì bài toán đây là
mình có sinh viên và lớp nhưng thực tế
rõ ràng là người tạo lớp trước bởi vì ở
lớp lớp 1 n đến sinh viên đúng không ạ
khi
mở một lớp
có nhiều sinh viên không ạ
Ừ mình chữa bài từ mức độ dễ để mức độ
cơ hội nâng cao lên một tí trong buổi
họp hôm nay nhé kiểu gì bụi cuối rồi mà
đúng không thì các bạn à biết lên được
tí gì hoặc chỉ đơn giản à đoạn nào mà
khó quá thì các bạn bỏ qua được không
ở tại sao tự nhiên thấy buồn vì a mình
mình có chữa bài cho các bạn thấy có khá
nhiều bạn cũng kiểu cũng hiểu được cái
đoạn này rồi thì thì các bạn đấy cũng
muốn mình chữa
em hát cho các bạn đấy là nó Tại sao lại
như thế mà rơi trường hợp nào cả
Tên này nhớ Vespa 50
đem một lớp l sinh viên trên 30 khi
một lớp l sinh viên thì mình nhiên mình
sẽ cả lớp trước Giờ xử mình ta sẽ làm
nun ni cả à
à à
thế này
sau đó đi mình sẽ
vợ bạn sinh viên
khi ekip Tân An ah
à à
anh
ở đây Mình sẽ lưu lại bạn lớp
In
iPhone kia
alo
nói mã này à
à à
nhà mình có thể thêm những cái check thì
kiểm tra tên các từ thứ đúng không
thì mình sẽ có thể thêm xuất ở đây mình
Online một tí kiến thức nhé
còn trên
một cái chết trái cây này ạ
len cổ tên
giờ lên bằng hai thứ tự chẳng hạn ạ
Đà Nẵng
Ừ rồi đúng không Bây giờ mình sẽ in shop
mình thiết vì Insert sau cái này chúng
sẽ into love
trình
an toàn thông tin ra sử vẫn luôn có hai
lớp à Mình ba lớp đi phải có một lớp thì
em mình lớp không còn sinh viên nào
Âm Nhạc
anh nói gì nhỉ lớp bảo trì máy tính đi ừ
số bản đồ sẽ
có sinh viên vào trong hai lớp đầu mình
định sẽ cho hạ sinh viên hai lớp đầu
Ừ đúng rồi có bạn thôi bình luận đúng
đấy Đó là nếu mà để thì 11 Lớp n sinh
viên và sinh viên cố định Mà lớp như này
đều nghĩa việc là một sinh viên mà chị
thuộc một lớp thôi nó không được phép
thuộc hai lớp Thôi thế này tím mình sẽ
chữa cần nâng cao đó là một sinh viên
với nhiều lớp thì sẽ như thế nào để các
bạn dễ hình dung I
Ỷ
Thiên Đồ Long
thì mình cứ sẽ lách lại cho nó chắc nhé
à
a123 Ok này
ở đây à
Ừ
anh
mời các bạn thế cũng chỉ có 3 sinh viên
nhưng mà thuộc hai lớp đầu đúng không ạ
a tiếp theo là Moon
hôm nay mình copy và nay tự tạo ra muốn
cũng rất nhanh thôi
e Mun nếu xong rồi mua chẳng cần phải
sửa còn gì nữa
cho anh chết rồi nhé
ở đó thế rồi chị sẽ in xuất
à à
bộ môn sẽ như này đổi tên nó là SQL này
Vì sao CP này
ở đó đi ỉa cho tim nhờ giao diện này
chắc lại ngon ba môn luôn đi ở đó
chỉ có bạn bè
anh ở đây mà toàn nó phức tạp hơn một tí
bởi vì à
ưu điểm di sản ở gần với sinh viên rồi
nó không
Ừ chị ạ một sinh viên
thì chắc chắn là có nhiều điểm
một môn
Ừ chắc chắn là có nhiều đi đúng không
Á và một sinh viên nổi đến môn ở thực ra
là qua cái bảng điện này nó ngon thì
khi thiếu kê thì các bạn thấy bài toán ở
đây
Ừ nó nó chỉ dừng giữa việc lại chị đây
mình để mình đi treo kiểu
anh có nhiều bạn muốn ghi thì mình sẽ
phải vẽ ra như thế này các bạn lên trang
grow.io gì vẽ nhé do em yêu thế các bạn
có thể vẽ được cái này đều ngoan
ừ ừ
các bạn Đợi mình tí à
Ừ thì nó sẽ có khái niệm mạng
anh NTT relations cái nó chỉ cái này các
bạn thì các bạn nhìn dễ hình dung thôi
chứ thực sự thì các bạn đấy mà không
theo ngành không phải thông tin này chị
các bạn có gì chẳng cần vỡ giờ động vào
đây làm gì cả
anh về đây nó sẽ khái niệm với cái thực
thể này
thế này có rất nhiều hơn anh thích điều
này
anh
à sinh viên này đúng không ạ
ở nhà đây sẽ là
Ô
Môn I
Ừ thì rõ ràng là thằng này một lời đến
này
a1n tháng ngày và thằn 1m lại thằng này
thì nó mối quan hệ men của bạn hoàn toàn
có thể nó là đấy nó sẽ là Mini túi mini
nó như sau
Ừ đúng
thì nó sẽ như này many-to-many trưởng
có bạn thắc mắc với mình là
ờ ờ
Ừ nhưng mà rõ ràng là
ở một lớp có thể có nhiều điểm mà đúng
không ạ
ở một lớp với cây kèn mối quan hệ nn này
để mà tạo ra cái bảng tạo ra một cái bạc
không phải tạo ra một thực thể đó nhé
tạo ra một cái bảng
ở đây mà lưu lại thông tin hay là ngày
vừa gọi là điểm để không ạ mối quan hệ
này là mình sẽ ghi đen
ở đó là tạo ra một tháng là thằng Điệp
nó sẽ lưu lại thông tin của hai thằng
này với nhau điều hòa
Ừ Thì
Ừ thì có bạn thắc mắc là rõ ràng là một
lớp thì sẽ thằng có thể có nhiều điểm
đúng không
Ừ nhưng mà bản chất là thằng sinh viên
này nó có lưu lại cái thằng mạ lớp rồi
Nhưng thực sự là các bạn không cần phải
thể hiện cái thằng lớp nối vào đây làm
gì cả
nó lớp đúng không ạ
Ừ chiều nay rõ ràng mà Một lớp có nhiều
sinh viên này
đã sửa ngày ạ ạ
à hài chú gà mình thấy là nó nói nó cứ
bị sao ấy
mẹ chồng hơi xóm tí Sao lại thế nhé em
Ừ thì các bạn thấy là
Ê thằng sinh viên và lưu lại mã lớp rồi
nhưng các bạn không cần phải nối mình
phải lưu lại cái việc lớp nói đến cái
thằng điểm hay nói thằng nào nữa Ở đây
Liên lại bảng điểm của mình thực tế nó
chỉ cần có là gì mình sẽ chỉ cần có đây
mình tạo luôn nhé
mã môn này kiểu in
bí mật mã sinh viên
cũng kiểu ý thế nào là xong rồi đầu
ngoặc
ông
chủ trường hợp Mà vừa nãy có bạn nói nói
chung về cái chuyên sâu thì tím mình sẽ
đề cập ok A
và để cho chắc chắn cái này đúng được là
các bạn phải thêm nút ở đây nữa nó mới
chuẩn đấy
không trường hợp mà mun có mà à mụn mã
môn hay mã sinh viên để trồng đúng không
là đương nhiên là có chút điện nữa đúng
không
Ừ quan điểm đã ba kia flash sản chẳng
hạn thế và điểm của mình nằm trong
nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến mưa chẳng hạn
mình mình tạm Coffee đây cho nhanh nhé
à à
phụ trách điểm ngoạn
Điền sẽ nằm trong
lớn hơn bằng không ạ em điểm nhỏ hơn
bằng 10 trở lại và khóa chính các bạn
nhớ hãy giúp của khóa chính trong bảng
này nó là gì
Chỉ có bạn là còn nhớ vợ lắm Mình hỏi
lại nhé Hoa chính trong bạn này theo các
bạn nó là những cục nào
nữ hoàng hoặc là cột Nam nhé
ừ ừ
33 bạn có 3 bạn trả lời nhưng cả ba bạn
thì đúng đúng hết rồi đúng không
Ừ Ok nó sẽ là mã môn cộng với mã sinh
viên đúng không không không không phải
là mỗi mã sinh viên Bởi vì nếu mà mỗi mã
sinh viên thì sinh viên để lặp lại nó sẽ
báo lỗi Đúng không
phim truyền hình sẽ không phá chính
là mã môn này là mã sinh viên thôi đúng
không
này tôi Giờ mình sẽ phải có khóa ngoại
cho nó nữa không phải khóa phụ mà khoáng
mại đúng không
xe tải mình sẽ có núi môn I
Ừ bà nội
a mã sinh viên sinh viên à
anh nói này
Khi nào xong rồi mà mình sẽ thử ý xuất
thử nhé ạ
ưu điểm giả sử là tất cả các cột này các
bạn hãy hiển nhiên tất cả cột đều phải
nhập nhưng mình có thể không ghi hẳn lại
tên cột nữa mà mình chỉ cần ghi theo
đúng thứ tự của các hội và được đã sửa
đây là bạn mã mua là một mã sinh viên là
một mà mình được 3 điểm trường ạ ngon à
ở đại và
à à
ý tưởng tượng là nếu mịn Sốt lại phát
nữa thì này mà kể cả mình nâng điểm lên
thì bạn sẽ thấy nó báo lỗi bởi vì nó có
liên quan đến đắp liên kết ki mà không
được phép chung cả hai cột cùng một lúc
Nhưng giả sử cùng cùng Môn đấy mạnh môn
là một mã sinh viên là hai thì nó sẽ
không nổi nữa đúng không
ừ ừ
có một khóa chính mình mình có đi cập
rồi đó là một quá trình có thể chứa rất
nhiều trường giá trị tất cả Nhiều cục nó
không sai gì cả
các bạn nên phân biệt dịch vụ đấy đúng
không
à à
Ừ ok ở chỗ nào Bây giờ giả sữa đang có
hạn một môn có
anh có hai sinh viên có điểm nóng và bạn
này Trượt cái môn này trở lại đây mình
sẽ cho bạn đấy á
Đỗ Đỗ Mun sau đi là một thứ hai bạn sinh
viên này cho rằng mưa đi làm đi bạn sẽ
đỗ được môn thứ hai của một thứ ba là
không không có bạn nào đã chi và bạn đã
đỗ không à Nhưng xin lỗi cái đoạn này
thì như rất nhanh cho mình tắt ra à
Ừ ở nhà đi Độc Lập
cô gọi đúng không đó sau đó thì bây giờ
làm bắt đầu lần lượt tất cả câu nhé
em lấy tất cả sinh viên kèm thông tin
lớp này
đề thi
Ừ cái này nè Thực ra là có bạn thì áp
dụng dùng rac roi da cũng đúng bởi vì
mình đã lỡ dùng từ sự tất cả sinh viên
đúng không xem lại cái ảnh bác nhỉ Hôm
nay có bạn gửi cho mình kể cả định bạn
đấy
đi làm làm riêng cho lớp mình cái ảnh sự
phát triển Xem xem xem lại
Ê mày bảo là cái ảnh hôm trước mình đăng
thức a nó chữ nó cứ bị mờ
à à
cho nên bạn làm hẳn lại cái ảnh ok
à vì thế ảnh này nó công nhận là nó rõ
ràng hơn
anh cũng đẹp hơn nó Các bạn nhìn được
đúng không Thì trong trường hợp này thì
mình cần lấy thông tin tất cả sinh viên
kèm trong tin Love
ở đó thì thực là câu hỏi nó vẫn hơn bị
mông lông mày tí nhà chắc là mình phải
sửa lại câu hỏi này một tí
ạ trà sữa ở đây nó có hai trường hợp đi
là sử ở đây là ở đây là thông tin đất
nếu có đi à
Ừ
thì thì mình sẽ là theo hình số trình
hình này đúng không Hình này là nếu là
sinh viên mà a và lớp là bê này ngon và
lấy hết toàn bộ thông tin của sinh viên
kèm thông tin lớp Nếu có bởi vì
à à Chồng chưa Mày đã không có sinh viên
nào không chụp lớp nào đúng không Mình
sẽ in giấc một sinh viên chất và nó
không nằm lớp nào nhé
cho Axelo
em
đánh vỡ lòng lắm chua cay
ở lớp là nguy các bạn ấy không thuộc lớp
nào cả ở đó
thế này thì rõ ràng các bạn sẽ thấy là
để lấy ra thông tin tất cả sinh viên thì
chắc chắn là phải dùng nét đẹp trôi đã
ngon và
cho mình
em chỉ thị thông tin rock ra nếu có thôi
chứ sao phòng sinh viên
cho Love On Love trên mã bằng sinh viên
Trần mã lớp
em có những các bạn chạy như này gọi sẽ
thấy da chị sẽ ra bốn bạn tất cả bạn
sinh viên kèm thông tin lớp Nếu có đúng
không
à à
Ừ ok tiếp theo là đến câu
anh tím số sinh viên theo từng lớp mỏng
thì cái này chắc chắn mà
thì các bạn thấy xe mạnh chút đã
cho mình thì mình sẽ kiểu Nga muốn xem
lại có các lớp như thế nào đã ngon
em xem lại cả lớp và sinh viên điện ảnh
cho tất cả hai câu sẵn ở
ở đây Anh có đang có ba lớp đúng không ạ
nhưng mà cái mạnh cái lớp thứ ba còn mãi
ông ba này thì không có sinh viên nào
đang nằm ở trong thì các bạn
bình thường là chính vị có ý dữ liệu như
này những cách tốt nhất để các bạn làm
đó là các bạn nên ghi hẳn ra đôi khi hẳn
nó phang xe đấy bây giờ như bây giờ mình
mẫu với anh xem nhé nào thì sẽ ghi lại
đáp án đúng một câu này để mình sau đó y
tế mình chẳng có lận đối chiếu theo em
thực sự là nó đã trùng chỉ chưa sửa mình
sẽ chị là mã rực tên của lớp này chẳng
ngại
ở Sao Đỏ cái gì số lượng sinh viên này ạ
ngon thì sẽ cần bạn lớp là một này tên
là đặt trình này số lượng sinh viên Lúc
này đang là hai chắc ạ xong rồi an toàn
thông tin này tượng sinh viên là một này
và
bên này bên A bảo trì máy tính này số
lượng sinh viên là không này Đấy mình
cần in ra được như thế này đúng không
Bây giờ mình bắt đầu làm
em chia đây à Các bạn thấy là
ô nhiễm mà lớp mình mình mình cứ thích
cho sinh viên nằm trước và lớp làm sau
cho các bạn được con luôn nhé trong
trường hợp này rõ ràng là mình một Lấy
toàn bộ lớp thì nó phải dùng vay cho
đúng không ạ
ở đây này
Ừ nhưng mà nếu mà xoay tròn
xe mini không dùng enjoyed được Tại sao
bộ kìa nó sẽ chỉ lấy phần chung này thôi
thì không có cái lớp không
anh không tồn tại được đúng không
Mà không không không có bạn sinh em là
đủ
ở bảng snack soundforge sinh viên ở
à à day.roi Plus
em copy giai đoạn này
khi
chạy thử nhé
ơi các bạn hãy sẽ ra được như này rồi
nhưng mà thực tế đề bài nói yêu cầu là
đếm mình sẽ dùng cao đúng không
bộ đếm đến cái gì
Ừ mình mà dùng cam sao đây thì nó sẽ sai
về mình sẽ được này
nữ ca sĩ ra là bún
các bạn thế là
đấy Mình phải copy hằn cái độc lập để
các bạn xem lại luôn luôn xem lại câu
con lệnh Nếu muốn có gì đó bất thường
nhé
bí đao xào Đây chỉ là đến tất cả bạn ghi
nó không Tuân thêm cái lớp nào cả Đúng
không liên là các bạn muốn
nhóm nó theo từng lớp nó rút bye đúng
không Lúc bay theo lớp chuẩn mã càng ạ
ở đó ra
211211 thì ra nó không đúng lắm
ở nhà mình có thử sendak lớp trầm mã ở
bên cạnh thì các bạn xem đã đúng không
ở đó
ở lớp thứ ba này không đúng bởi vì lớp
thứ ba số lượng cần là không đúng không
Thì mình sẽ cần Cao đây cụ thể là cao
với gì Bạn xem lại phát nữa này
và rõ ràng trong trường hợp này các bạn
thấy cái cột mày là cái giá trị ở đàn un
nên mình sẽ thấy cao cụ thể những cái
trường mà chắc chắn nó sẽ luôn cả nhà
thì mình loại bỏ loại bỏ nó để đến nó
không nó ngoài đến nó là một như thế này
nữa
ở mình thường hay là treo cái cột mà nó
đi qua thì cho nhà lại đúng không Chị sẽ
ăn lớp trên mã này nhé
cô sinh viên chụp mã lớp mình đúng sinh
viên trường mãi
khi đó nó sẽ ra số lượng đúng không ạ
số lượng sinh viên
mình nhìn cân theo quy tắc ta
mà đi số lượng sinh viên à
ở đâu ạ
anh ở đây mình sẽ trả lời thêm cho các
bạn về cái vụ
thì các bạn muốn anh chỉ ra tên nữa sự
lớp cùng tên như này
Các bạn thấy đôi khi nó sẽ báo lỗi như
này bởi vì nó không nằm trong danh sách
Goodbye Nhưng mình đừng nói vụ này rồi
thì cách để mà bạn lấy được cái cái tên
này thì các bạn sẽ phải Goodbye thêm ở
trong trong này này này thì mới lấy được
Ừ cái này nó chỉ nên áp dụng khi mà mã
các bạn hiển nhiên ngay cột đầu cậu tìm
ở Dubai thì nó đã phải là unique thì nó
phải là duy nhất rồi thì các bạn mới
dùng cái ngay được Tại sao bởi vì ở đây
mình sẽ chỉ được bạn thêm một tí bên
mình giờ xử lý ít thêm mình bạn một lớp
nữa
không nấu mì đang muốn đi chơi
Ừ ừ đó ngoại mang mà lớp mình tên của
lớp mình đang ở uống ít Sẵn rồi nên à
Cũng không ai mà không sao
chứ Nếu một tên lớp mà không Munich bị
Insert thêm một lớp nữa giống như tên
sau đó đi mình Goodbye theo lớp trưởng
tên ý thì 2 lớp để nó sẽ Gộp chung lại
một các bạn hình dung được cái vụ đâu
Ừ cái này gì tí mình làm về vụ điểm được
làm phụ về vụ điện theo từng sinh viên
và mình cho tên sinh viên các bạn trùng
nhau thì các bạn sẽ thấy hiểu tại sao
điều hòa
vì đ
em lấy sinh viên kèm điểm và tên môn thì
nó sẽ như thế nào
Ừ thì đây mình cứ giá giả sự nhé giả sự
là bài toán dễ trước đi là
à mà trong trường hợp mà bắt buộc sinh
viên là phải có điểm và có mày phải có
điểm
ở đâu ạ thì sẽ như thế nào mình sẽ back
sao from sinh viên này
sau đó thì do chính xác lại Android Đúng
bia on điểm chuẩn mã sinh viên này bằng
Sinh viên chấm mã này
Ừ nếu mà chạy này thôi thì mình sẽ ra
được thông tin sinh viên à cảnh điểm của
bạn đây là sửa là mình cứ lấy thông tin
nhiều da hơn nhiều mình xử lý Lấy mũi
tên của Seagame nhé Candy ạ
khi chấm điểm mà chẳng ạ ạ
ở đó
ở những nhưng mà mình cần lấy thật tên
môn nữa đúng không Mình nên cả cái môn
nữa thì mình lại mình không thể ghi hai
câu xà lách độc lập được mà bây giờ phải
toán ở đây đó là mình sẽ phải nối Thế em
gửi cái thằng nối thêm một cái thằng à
môn nữa thì có nhiều bạn sẽ thấy à của
rõ ràng là ở đây anh đang dạy có nhân
này hình thôi đúng không ạ
ở đây Hoàng Sinh viên rồi đấy Thằng điểm
nữa đau thằng C nữa Ngoan Làm gì có
thằng C nữa để mình ghi câu truy vấn
thực tế là khi mặc bạn cho xong ấy nó
lại gộp chung thành một bạn to hơn
và bàn đấy còn toàn thể do tiếp Vì những
bản nữa
em thậm chí căn chòi lại khó có cả vụ
cho lại đến chính nó cũng được không sao
cả ship nhỉ các bạn cho lại mạnh sinh
diện được rồi lần thì ý mình ạ khi mà
các bạn cho rồi bản chất Nó là một cái
bảng rồi và các bạn lại cho tiếp đến
bang khác như bình thường thôi chứ chưa
cho nên trong trường hợp này mình sẽ
lại phải dùng bên vẽ đi
ở đâu mà mình sử dụng bên vẻ nhé
à à
các bạn hôm nay tôi sẽ vẻ đẹp hơn không
tin tôi đi
hình ảnh sự như này
thì sẽ đây là sinh viên à
ở
đây là sinh viên trước nó ngoại
cô sinh viên là sự sinh viên Các bạn
thấy là
ở bên này và sự biến là điểm đi
cho anh nhé điểm
đề thi
à
mình mình phải xem lại bên là một chút
nhỉ đã có 3 bạn sinh viên không ạ
33 bạn sinh viên
a b d b trong trường hợp in New York tất
cả 3 mạng sinh viên đều có điểm này ba
sinh viên và 3 điểm out
A và thực tế mình có bốn mạng sinh viên
một sinh viên là không có điện sẽ làm
đến anh ạ
do đánh mà đưa nghe không có trường hợp
mà
à
Mà điểm tồn tại mà mà mà mà không thuộc
sinh viên nào được nghe vô lý bọn đấy nó
sẽ như thế này mà từ và từ Cái câu sẽ
lách của mình vừa rồi nhìn này đó ngon
và sẽ lấy cái phần này và đẩy mình vừa
rồi Mình đang đẩy đúng mùa xuân này đúng
không ạ anh bật từ phần này của mình sẽ
lại biến thành một hàng nữa vào thành
bảng mới
thì mình sẽ đây là sinh viên điểm vào
đây mình sẽ nối tiếp với thằng Moon
Ý bạn là hơi đau đồng ý mình thằng định
đoạn này nó bao lâu
cộng điểm A
anh nhìn enter xuống dòng thì nhé
à à
thì mình sẽ nối để thằng ạ
ở
nhà hơi bé
À mà đây các bạn nhiều nó ba sinh viên
điểm đúng không thấy sẽ làm Môn Đúng
không môn
hình ảnh và mình sẽ cần lấy cái gì mình
cần lấy tên môn đối ngoại giữa trả nợ
mình sẽ chỉ mày cái thằng ở giữa ấy thôi
một viên cảnh đầy tên môn kẽm của sinh
viên có biển này thôi chúng mình không
cần lấy những cái môn mà không
anh không liên quan gì là sinh viên là
điện với cả nghĩa là mình sẽ phải dùng
cái hình Diệp mình sẽ phải dùng những
hình ảnh chị sẽ dùng inuya tiếp trước
ngoại dùng redtours hay dùng vay doi có
bạn hôm nay trả lời trả lời mấy câu hỏi
bài tập này thì bạn ơi Không hiểu đi
thì mình sẽ dùng in New York được chưa
cái tổng kết của cái nãy giờ mình đang
giải thích nó thế chúng ta sẽ quay dùng
in New York để mà lấy ra được tên Moon
chứ không phải dùng lap doi fireflies
anh
bởi vì mình cần lấy những cái á
Anh tên môn của cái điểm mà thua mày
đúng không ạ Mình không cần phải lấy ra
ăn thừa cái môn cũng không không phải
dùng đất cho làm gì cả Bởi vì chắc chắn
lại Ừ cái cái thằng ở bên này nó không
trống không không có trống
à mà nó tập trung hết vào bên này mới
chuẩn đấy tôi bị điểm không có trường
hợp Điệp không thuộc môn nào vô lý rồi
nên không không cần quan tâm điều đấy
à à xe
tải phim sex mạnh có ba sinh viên
3 điểm
và hai môn đầu ngon và ở đây sẽ là một
môn ở ngoài này thôi Đúng đấy nó sẽ như
thế này
E bằng cách viết thì vừa rồi Các bạn xem
rồi đấy ngon mình sẽ roi
Mun on Moon Trần mã bằng điểm chuẩn mã
Môn
em gọi cho mình sự select Ê mày làm mun
chấm hết
Dù có xảy ra nhưng
a porta
à à Ừ thì đây mình sẽ là
mình sẽ lại devit ý cho các bạn dễ hiểu
sinh viên có đỉa
à à
ở Mỹ
em hoặc lấy tên mặt hơn hàng thật chỉ
cần nghe em thấy sinh viên có điểm kèm
cho em môn tại như thế này nó
Đi bẫy kịch cầu câu hỏi sẽ nên là nhìn
lại tuổi trẻ
à Còn nếu mà trong trường hợp mà bạn
muốn lấy tất cả sinh viên
Anh không quan tâm bạn phải có điểm 20
điều hòa không quan tâm mày có điểm 20
quyn hết ra thì chồng + đãi các bạn phải
có bún sinh viên mới đúng cái bạn ạ
Ừ cái bạn là 5 5S Kai này lại không
thuộc lớp nào và bạn cũng chẳng có điểm
nào chẳng hạn đúng không ạ
Ừ thì cần phải có bạn đấy hoặc mặt anh
đúng rồi bạn anh nữa nhỉ Anh này đúng
không Bạn không có điểm mà đúng không
anh đúng không có điều mà cả thì cần in
bạn ấy ra ở đây thì như thế nào Vì rõ
ràng các bạn thử xem các bạn đôi khi vậy
Xem xe Lead lại nhóm sinh viên nhé đấy
có tổng cộng có bốn bạn ở đây nhìn nhìn
rồi đây Các bạn nhìn có vẻ là nó ra 3
bàn ghi được ra ở đây đang có mỗi hai
sinh viên thôi chúng ngoài bà sinh viên
mà bọn thì đây mình sẽ
lấy tất cả
sinh viên
kèm bia Nếu có đi
thì chắc chắn là đây em đề bài khác luôn
và là cách giải quyết của nó sẽ là gì
Ngay từ lúc lấy sinh viên và bìa thì
mình phải dùng lá cho rồi mình sẽ không
dùng in New York nữa mình sẽ copy cái
đoạn này nhé
đi xóa lại đi xóa ra đây Cái này trước
đi lấy sẽ dùng ghép loa này Đó chạy thử
này các bạn sẽ thấy là đây nó đang ra
đúng nó đang ra đúng là
À mà đây axit tên tên thông tin sinh
viên và điểm Nếu có đúng là nun mà không
ạ
anh em
a
stream mình sẽ sáng lại nói liên tục rồi
thì ra đấy cũng là nhược điểm và cũng là
ưu điểm cho các bạn nhược điểm đó là gì
đó là mình dại chiến trường ấy thì thực
hành cần yêu một trăm phần trăm mình dậy
đến đâu
mình sẽ dừng lại ở một đoạn nào đó để
các bạn sẽ phải gõ lại để các bạn tự
hình dung từ hiểm các bạn không bị có
tải các bạn không nghe một trang như này
Ừ nhưng mà chui như thế này thì mình
không thể mình ngồi đợi các bạn mồi làm
xong rồi thắc mắt được nên mình phải dậy
một trang nhưng các bạn sẽ bị quá tải
Ừ nhưng mà đây cũng ngại yêu ở điểm là
chính vì là chim không trực các bạn hoàn
toàn để xem lại bạn nãy giờ các bạn nên
tôi lại nếu mà các bạn thấy đoạn nào nó
bị choáng quá các bạn tạm dừng lại được
không ạ à còn như mình đã nói thì
thì các bạn đau đầu thực ra mình thấy
tốt
em thấy mình đã từng nó rồi các bạn đau
đầu này đó là não các bạn đang đẩy đúng
không là các bạn đang tư duy theo mình
nên là mình thấy
trừ khi các bạn thấy cực kỳ khó nghe mãi
không hiểu Xem lại video cũng không hiểu
à mà rất nhiều bạn như thế thì chắc mình
phải xem lại cái Dậy thôi ngoại Còn bây
giờ thì
ở
bài này vẫn chưa là nâng cao chưa chuyên
sâu làm nên á Các bạn phải chịu khó một
tí không ạ
em bận bận hạt 1.75 là ông khóc đấy Đấy
do mà nãy mình đã từng nói vụ là mình
đang cố nói chậm cũng là để cho các bạn
nghe từ từ thẩm đối ngoại em chưa bây
giờ mà mình còn bắn rát nhưng kết hợp
việc mình giảng nhanh như này nữa
không ai dặn nhanh như này giảm nhanh
nữa cháu ạ Chịu chị lúc hoặc
Ừ
thì bên này mình sẽ vẽ lại cái hình một
tí ạ thì các bạn thấy là bây giờ trong
trường hợp này nó bốn sinh viên mất rồi
đúng không ạ 4 sinh viên
Ừ chúc 73 nữa lại mình sẽ sửa lại gì
34 sinh viên à
Ừ tôi đã lấy đi đây là buồn nhé
à à
CH4 này
đề thi
34 sinh viên nhưng mà vẫn chỉ có 3 điểm
thôi đúng không
A và
chú ý
Ừ đúng nhỉ
1000 độ mình tính bị bắt đầu loạn xin
lỗi xin lỗi xin lỗi à
ở đây đây đây đây à
anh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
à à Có hai sinh viên à
anh Hai sinh viên
anh không Không có điện được ngon hai
sinh viên không có điện
ở đó chuẩn này
Ừ đúng
D3 sinh viên ba điểm 2 môn nó vẫn nằm ở
đây nó vẫn đúng nhưng mà có hai sinh
viên không có điểm chuẩn thi ạ Và bây
giờ mình cần lấy vẫn phải cần lấy tất cả
sinh viên mà đồng ngoại
à à đoạn này vừa nãy mình nhầm đấy mình
mình vừa nãy thì có bao An khi mình bị
nhầm đấy ông ạ ngay từ lúc đầu nãy giờ
là đang chỉ có hai sinh viên kém 3 điểm
đồng đều ngon và hai sinh viên không có
điểm đều ngon
anh hả
cô
sinh viên không có điểm thì đâu nằm ở
hình dưới
3000 ý mình nhé là trong trường hợp Lần
này là mình lấy toàn bộ sinh viên kèm
điểm rồi mà đúng không
ở cái đoạn này Mình bị nhầm đấy nha Cái
đoạn này phải là hay đấy Mình vừa nãy
nhìn nhìn nhầm Xin lỗi các bạn đây phải
là hai sinh viên không điều này hay sinh
viên có 3 điểm đúng chưa Đấy Và mình đã
lần này mình lấy toàn bộ cái nét cho em
à Ngon mình mình sẽ lại đúng không Mình
lấy toàn bộ ghép cho này khi xuống đây
nó sẽ ôm y nguyên cái đấy Xuống đây thôi
Đúng ngoạn mình sẽ là nối tiếp 3 điểm
thì nói đến 2 môn thì ra đây rồi đóng
ngoặc hai sinh viên này hay sinh viên
không có điểm đó Phần thưởng thì bây giờ
trong trường hợp này các bạn vẫn muốn
lấy toàn bộ tất cả sinh viên không ạ thì
mình lại phải dùng nét cho tiếp thôi ông
ạ
thì mình sẽ không dùng enjoyed bởi vì
Windows thì lại bị loại bỏ mất sinh viên
không có điểm nó rồi không ạ Nghe có vẻ
rất phức tạp gì đấy nhưng mà bây giờ
mình thêm mỗi người ra ngoài thôi mà
mình copy ở đây
đổi nó thành nét gói
Ê bà Đương nhiên lấy tên môn để các bạn
xem qua thì các bạn sẽ hình dung này là
xong
khi đó nó sẽ ra tên sinh viên nhưng mà
không có điểm thế không có điểm này sẽ
không có tên môn không
ở đó
Ẩm Thực ra là hồi mà mình học với cái
cho này mình khẳng định và các bạn luôn
đó là mình chẳng hiểu gì cả một phần là
do thầy dạy lý thuyết quá và xài không
giảm
em xấu lắm Theo mình là thế
cho nên là ngồi đấy mới đúng kiểu như
thế này
thì
mình cứ đầu tiên mình có dùng in cho
chạy thấy ra cái quạt xài thì bắt đầu
kiểu lên hay càng lên LED Joyride do
nhưng sẽ chạy ra kết quả thì thôi đấy
tưởng ý thế
Vì thế nên là
ông bà và mãi thì sau nhé mãi về sau khi
mà mình động hẳn sang cái á à Cái đồ ăn
hay và nãy mình có đi cà phê Cái trang
web chuyên sâu ấy làm nối phải có là đấy
mình phải làm đến mười mấy cái bạn ấy
chắc chắn là sẽ Kiều a cho dùm cái thứ
loạn hết cả lên để lấy thông tin chứ Thì
lúc đấy Thực sự thì mò kiểu như thế thì
vỡ mồm ngân hàng ra phải hiểu bản chất
của cái cho con à
Ừ đúng rồi Ông kia nói chuẩn hình thức
ấy thì Đức viết Cảm tất cả hình thức pha
tất cả cứ kiểm tra hết mọi trường hợp
với ra kết quả đúng đi thôi nhưng mình
không nên như thế mình chơi kiểu như thế
thì nó bị không tốt đúng không
Nhưng mà mình dàn đoạn này hi vọng là
nãy giờ các bạn
A gọi nhá nhem 10 nhưng mà hiểu được năm
sáu là tốt rồi chưa năm sáu rất là tốt
rồi thì mình xem lại thì mình hiểu thêm
các thứ thứ nữa là ngon
Có chứ bây giờ mà mình dậy xong dậy một
mà các bạn hiểu 10 cho các bạn không
ngồi đây rồi không ạ
ờ
ờ gà đến bây giờ thấy mình thấy sợ các
bạn đang hơi choáng thôi
Ừ nhưng mà từ từ bước từ những bước vừa
rồi thì làm những câu sau này rất là dễ
à mình mình nghĩa là làm câu sao mày từ
từ cái bước lấy được thông tin kia đúng
không thông tin của đĩa các thứ thứ rồi
thì thì mình việc mình
lấy cái này thì ra lại dễ này để mình
cho bạn xem nhé á
anh kia mày hiểu cái trên này mình lấy
thông tin điểm được rồi đúng không Thì
được Ca bây giờ là lần này mình không
cần nói đến môn nữa mình không cần lấy
tên môn nữa Mình chỉ cần lấy điểm trung
bình của từng sinh viên mà mua
anh alo không phải cuộc tình sinh viên
luôn của lớp này đúng không Tuy có sao
U30 thức thử nhé sẽ sao sinh viên này
chắc chắn là lâu mới đi phút này
à à
địa điểm trung bình thế xã Nam mình sẽ
cần sinh viên này chắc chắn phải có điểm
này là cho đến điểm này on điểm chấm mã
sinh viên bằng Sinh viên chấm mãi
ở đầu tiên mình chạy thử nha đã đồng
loại thì các bạn xem qua đây để mày hình
dung đã này thì
em không có bạn nào ở lớp thứ 2 hay lớp
thứ ba là có điểm đúng hoặc không có bạn
nào cả thì mình cần in ra kết quả là
điểm trung bình của lớp thứ Hai thứ Ba
và new là chấm Đúng không a a và điểm
trung bình của lớp thứ nhất thì sẽ bằng
ba ngày nay cộng lại rồi chia chia cho 3
chở nhận đúng không ạ
Ừ thì đây mình cầm cho anh tiếp với lớp
on love
300 mã bằng
cô
sinh viên Trần mã lớp này mình có chạy
thử cho bạn nhé chạy thử trước đây các
bạn sẽ thấy à
Ừ nó lại Chỉ ra mỗi lớp lập trình đó
ngoại ra mỗi lớp mỗi lập trình mình mình
đang giảm theo cậu là từ từ cốt sang
sang cái ảnh này nhá vừa rồi Mình làm từ
ảnh xanh cốt mà mình rằng ngược lại vậy
nhé chị xem các bạn thấy
hiểu bằng cả hai cách càng tốt đâu ngon
đấy chứ Làm cách nào để mình sẽ ra thông
tin được toàn bộ các lớp Đồng hoặc mình
sẽ chỉ đầy đủ các lớp ở đây thì đây mình
đương nhiên là lớp cái thằng lớp này
khi họ đang nhiều hơn so với hạt cái
thơm vừa rồi này không ạ thì mình sẽ
phải vay doi ngay thôi đó thì mình sẽ ra
được thông tin của lớp ở bên bên ai đúng
không ạ
A và đôi nhà lớp mày không có sinh viên
nào
em có điểm chính Sao thế Không phải
không có sinh viên nào đúng
a a đoạn bọn này hơi loạn
Em định vị Bình tĩnh bình tĩnh ý nghĩa
cách này thì là không tốt đoạn này làm
này có khi xa nữa rồi
anh Đợi mình tí
Ừ nếu trong trường hợp này như thế thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là để lấy được thông tin
của sinh viên của bạn của lớp này chẳng
qua là không
sao bạn lại không có điểm gì
Ừ thì mình sẽ phải nói thằng lớp thì
thằng sinh viên trước rồi mà nó mày nói
đến điểm nhưng mà trong trường hợp máy
chở ra cũng được cái này mình Nếu mình
chỉ còn quan tâm là lấy điểm trung bình
thì là cái thang này bắt buộc phải chấm
nó ngoan Nếu Samsung và lớp này không
được Tại Arab này không có sinh sinh
viên có điểm thì cái này chồng cũng được
trả qua nhìn này trông có vẻ là lâu mày
không có cặp sinh viên ở ngoại
à à xe tảibáo loạn
ừ ừ
Ừ Thì bây giờ mình cứ giả sử mình sẽ là
em lấy điểm trung bình của chị sẽ là AVG
này điện này à
khi chạy thử cho bạn xem này
chị sẽ ra sáu nó là điểm của tất cả các
sinh viên đang có điện rồi lấy Trung
bình thì thế không đúng về mình đang cần
lấy theo từng lớp một thôi thì mình sẽ
giúp anh ạ
anh
bóp chấm mã nghe chẳng hạn
ạ sau đó đi mình sẽ like để các bạn dễ
hình dung mà Rốt cuộc nó lắm ạ có điểm
trung bình ngày của lớp nào đúng không ạ
đó sẽ ra như thế này Ok Thế xong đúng
không
à À cái này của lớp lập trình không phải
của từng lớp
ở đây cho mình trả lời công an nữa rồi
Nhưng mà nếu mà của lớp lớp lập trình
thì K Mình không dùng Goodbye nữa các
bạn bản chất thì đấy
hè từng lớp được ạ
thì ra nó tương tự như mạng đâu mà còn
lớp lập trình mình hay good bye thằng
que
I love chấm tên bằng lập trình thôi và
cái này thì mình có thể lấy lớp chúng
tên luôn cũng được Chạy thử đấy
à à lớp chúng tôi không nằm trong cái
bài này đã bỏ mày đi ỉa đúng không chạy
thử nè
thì nó sẽ là Sáu đúng không ạ
à Còn nếu mà các bạn muốn in ra cả lớp
trưởng tên nữa thì đúng là các bạn phải
giúp anh theo lớp 9 tên nữa cho dù ở thì
ra là mình thấy thật ra thằng web này có
nhược điểm như thế thằng mai que thì các
bạn không cần phải select a a không phải
có Goodbye các bạn vẫn lấy được cái đoạn
sẽ lấy cái ra à ừ ừ
Ừ ok đấy Loại này thì ra các bạn hơi bị
có tại đấy nhớ gọi mình trả lời nốt câu
này cho bạn đợi cho anh nhé
khi Đảng Cộng sản cho nốt
ở bãi biển sẽ copy nói câu này
à à
Ê
bà con này Thực ra là nếu mà Bể để làm
nhanh ấy để làm nhanh cho các bạn ấy thì
các bạn hoàn toàn thì hai cái từ lớp này
thành môn là chạy được thôi ông ạ nhưng
lần này mình xin phép mình giải thích
lại theo cái hình này
à mình mình thích dùng hình này thế của
việc hình này nó sẽ hấp thụ được cho các
bạn làm bao nhiêu bạn bao nhiêu Bảng
cũng cũng đủ
Ừ
chúc bạn cũng cũng ổn không không cần
nhất thiết phải hiểu chỉ mỗi ba bạn như
thế này
anh đúng không Mình mình đang hướng dẫn
là nhiều bạn mà ngon
bộ phim
à mà ít người xem
Ừ đúng đến cái đoạn trả lời mấy câu Sao
mấy ông đang rụng rời hết tôi biết mà
có thể thao là cái này đồng nghĩa là sao
bởi vì cái này nó cũng
anh cũng không có bạn các bạn không cần
phải biết lắm như là mình đang giải
thích để các bạn hiểu từng tận với cái
riêng cho nhà và Tiệc Các bạn không cần
phải sợ nó nữa nếu mà các bạn đang học
ngành Công nghệ thông tin theo ngày
không phải thông tin mình thấy đây là
một trong những bài khó nhất
Ừ thôi Của mình học công nghệ tin đó là
với cái trò này sau đó tiếp theo là về
Goodbye khó nhất đấy thì thế nên là mình
mới đang phải dạng các bạn rất kỹ và
phải có hình ảnh minh họa trước bạn nhớ
là những cái buổi buổi kia thì mình có
đâu phải ráng kỹ như thế này và đâu có
hình minh họa gì đâu ạ Không ạ
ở bước cuối nó chả phải khói mấy cái bụi
trước ông không thể mong chờ buổi một
cuối dễ hơn cả buổi đầu đấy thế Thấy say
quá đi
ông
già nuốt với đoạn này cho các bạn hình
chung rồi mình tặng nhìn nhé à
anh à Mấy cái dạng chuẩn khó nhá Không
không béo nói về để SQL cơ bản còn nếu
mà về cái dạng chuẩn nó nhảy sang cái
môi cấu trúc dữ liệu mất rồi
ông ngoại ông nào mà đang học trước mấy
cái này mà đến lớp học thì cái này đi Tự
nhiên lại biến thành ông trùm chị dò
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này nó atwell thì toàn bộ
những câu lệnh này nãy giờ chạy bên mái
queo vẫn được nhé
ừ ừ
ở trên trường nó Đôi khi thấy mấy cái
này khó quá mấy thấy cô không dậy xong
thế này đâu Mấy cô dậy nước qua đấy
Ừ rồi nói cho mình xin phép trả lời nói
nhé xe
tải mình sẽ vẽ lại cái hình tính
Ê trái đi
em thật sự đây mình sẽ có là sinh viên
không ạ à à
ở SEA Games
cô
sinh viên của mình và bên này mình sẽ là
điểm đi điểm
a cho hình cũ cũng được nhà mình cứ vẽ
lại đi mình sẽ có hai sinh viên không có
điểm nào Hà
Ê bà hai sinh viên có điểm
có body Bà Điểm
à mà đương nhiên là không có trường hợp
nào là điểm có mà sinh viên không có
đúng không cái đoạn này thì các bạn hiểu
rồi đúng không
Ừ đấy tiếp theo là mình lại vẽ tiếp
ở trong trường hợp mà mình mình cần mình
cần lấy điểm trung bình đúng không Các
bạn thấy rõ ràng mình cần lấy Điệp Chúng
Mình
địa chỉ rõ ràng này hiển nhiên là mình
ừ ừ
Anh của của môn cụ thể thì không phải là
điểm trung bình của tất cả sinh viên
đúng không Thì rõ ra mà mình không cần
phải lấy cái thằng hai sinh viên này ra
làm gì cả mà mình chỉ cần lấy à
thì mình nghĩ là bây giờ để có hai hướng
làm nhé Mình mình sẽ giải thích theo
kiểu hai hướng đi để các bạn thấy thực
ra nó cái nết hay like do nó không không
cần gì ở đây cả mình đang làm bài toán
nó hơi bị ngược một tí nhưng không sao
332 sinh viên và 3 điểm và mình sẽ chỉ
cần lấy cái đoạn này thôi này anh mình
sẽ ghi ở đây là
anh cứ sinh viên gọi điện cho nhé đã
cô
sinh viên cộng điểm A
chị sẽ là
anh Hai sinh viên này
chị đã 3 điểm và là hai môn
anh đùa
bạn trong trường hợp này thì sẽ không có
thằng thừa nữa đúng không
số bài 5 trường hợp này sẽ là môn thì sẽ
có
A1 môn không có điện đấy đúng không em
ở những nhưng mà cái bài toán ở đây là
nếu mà các bạn làm theo kiểu Goodbye
theo từng môn thì nó mới phức tạp
à Còn nếu các bạn quay theo môn cụ thể
này rồi thì bạn có khi em các bạn đơn
giản là kiểm tra xem mô này nó có điểm
hay không là do kết quả rồi thực tế như
thế nhưng mình cứ làm theo kiểu bài toán
là mình cứ led cho cháu thử như này nhé
chỉ có 3 điểm ấy ạ
là một sinh viên có mua sinh viên có hại
hay điểm hình thành ra nó thành 3 điểm
đấy mình sẽ lách lại các bạn xem nhé đây
tôi sẽ lấy từ hình trên đi bạn sẽ dùng
Black
sao bom
sinh viên à
a cho e với biển
ở Hòn điểm chấm mã sinh viên Phạm sinh
viên mãn ạ
à à
ở đây Các bạn thấy rõ ràng là có 3 điểm
đấy nhá 123 mà đúng không Nhưng thực ra
có mỗi hai sinh viên thôi Cái này mình
đoạn này 12 sinh viên 3 Địa đều ngoan ý
A và từ đây thì các bạn thấy là nó chỉ
có 2 môn đấy các bạn thấy nó có 2 môn
thôi
Ừ hai môi và một môn Chắc chắn không có
điên đúng không
nhà mình cần lấy mình cần lấy ở đây em
mình cứ cầm lấy tất cả các môn này đã
sau đó thì mình mới kiểm tra xem đã cái
mô nasware nó có điểm hay không thì rõ
ra dùng cái này dùng da do đúng không ạ
dai cho bởi ngôn on luôn trầm mã bằng
đỉa chàm mã môn này đó thế này sẽ thử
này
ở đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy là muốn HTML
này không có điểm muốn pp này có một
điểm và muộn atwell này có 2 điểm hoa
bên này mình khóe
môn trầm tên bằng spoj là xong này
Anh ở trại này
ở đó mình khuyên các bạn nên sẽ Click
sao trước trước khi mà làm cái cái câu
lên quan đến lấy điểm trúng Bình hay cái
gì như thế này họ từ đây thì có bạn sẽ
lấy ra Thôi mua chị sẽ lấy điểm trúng
Bính điểm này nó xong
khi
xảy ra 4 điên
A và bể bể cái vừa nãy mình nói là thực
ra các bạn thể làm ngược lại được
Ừ nếu mà bà bảng này các bạn hoàn toàn
thể lấy từ môn nối với điểm trước
ở đâu mà từ môn lấy điểm trước mình sẽ
lại Xóa Địt
xin phép buồn cuối mình nói hơi phức tạp
một tí à à
The Moon
à à
em có một môn không có điểm có
ưu điểm
ở đây nhớ không có điểm nào không thuộc
môn nào đúng không ạ Bà có 2 môn có 3
điểm ở
á nhon
thì mình sẽ lấy cái này chứ
ừ thì đương nhiên là mình quy tắc ở đây
là mình cần lấy là lấy tất cả các môn
trước đã
thế này lấy cái toàn bộ Cái bên trái lên
trước có bạn bảo với mình là tại sao anh
không lấy ngay từ loại ngay từ trường
hợp này
Ừ mình nhà quê luôn
quay luôn kiểm tra xe và mô nasware đấy
có điểm 20 đến mình đỡ mất công cho dùng
rồi nữa đấy giờ ra vẫn làm được
Ừ nhưng mà nó sẽ tốn hai câu c lách một
câu select là các bạn ấy kiểm tra xem đã
mua này có điện hay không Tôi có sẽ lấy
thứ hai là nếu có thì lấy còn đây mình
giải quyết bài toán là mình cứ gia sư
hiển nhiên là không biết được là
là môn này có điểm hay không Mình có
phải doi Cát Tường sử dụng mì que đấu
ngoạn đi
Ừ cái thì cái đoạn mày thì các bạn sẽ
thấy là nó tương tự giống hình về nãy là
mình cũng sẽ
ở lại cho tiếp thôi
thế này
ở đây sẽ lá muốn cộng điểm
hai tay vẫn sẽ làm một vào đây vẫn sẽ là
hai môn
3 điểm và hai sinh viên
ở đây sẽ là sinh viên
có một ngày
thì alo anh nhé
à à
em
à Đợi tí hình em làm mình đang làm gì đó
nó hơi thường mất rồi
Ừ mình mới chợt nhận ra là mình không
cần phải lại trôi hoài sinh viên thì xin
lỗi nãy có vẻ phức tạp quá
em
làm phức tạp quá Anh xin lỗi gì lỗi
nhưng cái đoạn này nó chỉ đơn giản việc
là cái đoạn này xong rồi
chị
sẽ sao điểm
có nét trôi điểm
đúng ngoài ra lấy môn rồi lấy điểm là
xong rồi mình quên mất tự nhiên mình cứ
bị Rập khuôn mình phải lấy ra sinh viên
Anh xin lỗi các bạn ạ
vụ
bạo loạn
thế cái roi này làm cái thử nó
em khá đau não à
xe điện trên mạng môn bằng môn cho mày
Chị xem thử cái này đã này thì lấy tất
cả các môn kèm theo bia không
Ông Bà mình sẽ Wen theo
mun chấm tên = FeO đ
anh ra được ngay rồi bà pin bây giờ mình
sẽ chỉ cần
lấy điểm thôi
ừ ừ
tại sao mình tự nhiên đi rồi sinh viên
nghỉ
á Vừa nãy mình cho sinh viên Mày trong
trường hợp trên này đúng một mình cần
theo lấy cả cho cả lớp để lấy tên nữa
À mình quên mất mà thực ra ở dưới này
thì mình không cần vậy cho em sinh viên
ngay nữa xin lỗi
anh Xóa ngay đi
Á Đù
Ừ mình cũng đủ với các bạn rồi Xin lỗi
nhưng sao mình mình nghĩ là
Ừ cái này là lỗi à
ai kể cả người đi làm rồi Đỗ Sỹ hay bị
lùi như thế
à à
Ừ mình chia sẻ thực tế và mình cũng sẽ
thừa nhận mình sai mà đúng không
à Nhưng cái này là cái bài toán nãy giờ
mình đang dạy các bạn không phải là cái
mũ kiến thức mà tư duy của một dân lập
trình
sau khi mà giải quyết một bài toán
Vì thế nên là có trường hợp mà mình có
thể mình đi code ra sai
A và mình sẽ chỉ các bạn cách khắc phục
các thứ thứ bàn Thượng đứng ở sẽ thừa
nhận mình sai như là
không khác với kiểu thầy cô thường là
Ừ thì cô à
Ừ thì cô thường mình đã từng từng học
ở đó là như mình như mình đừng nói đó đó
là các thầy cô thấy cái này khó quá có
thể có dạng nhanh và cố tình
thì mình Phải khẳng định đôi khi có một
vài thầy cô cố tình là không đề cập
ý thức a mình mình biết cái đấy
anh không đề cập em mấy cái khó này
Ừ mình đang dạy các bạn và mình đang
thấy là lượng người xem anh giảm thời
gian mình không Đương nhiên rất là mình
không vui đấy nhưng mà mình thấy cái này
thời ra có nhiều bạn hò Linh quá và
chính bản thân mình đã từng bị khó chịu
khi mà
sau khi làm được các thầy cô kiểu dậy
không có tâm đấy dậy nên là mình làm
phải cố dạy các bạn chấp nhận là cái này
nó rất là khó làm cho các bạn cảm thấy
tai nạn có
Ừ nhưng mà đây là mình đang hướng đến là
cho các bạn đang xem ảnh công nghệ công
ty mà đúng ngọn còn là các bạn các bạn
Mà đang học cơ bản thì các bạn bỏ ngay
từ cái đoạn cô sao mày rồi là được rồi
đấy là sự thật cũng không cần phải biết
quá đến mức độ như này à
thế nhưng các bạn mà đoạn câu sau này
nãy giờ mà thấy lâu quá không hiểu thì
mình
anh không thấy vấn đề gì cả
Ừ đúng rồi vì nhiều thầy cô
có nhiều thầy cô kiểu
Anh luôn muốn mình là kéo luôn được Quan
điểm trong trong mắt các sinh viên là
thầy cô luôn đúng cũng nhờ thầy cô rằng
dễ hiểu
Ừ mình không đây như mình rất vui khi
các bạn nói rằng dễ hiểu 2 á tha thứ
nhưng mà nãy giờ mình đang dạy những cái
mà thực ra nào mình khẳng định luôn nó
không hề dễ thì dễ hiểu tệ nào mình chấp
nhận điều đấy chấp nhận bài toàn đây để
mà để mà
nói chung là vì giúp các bạn đúng không
ạ
Ừ đúng rồi Còn cái vụ cốt mà ráng ráng
chiều mưa đuổi học sinh mà
thì các bạn Nói chung là các bạn là banh
đang theo ngày cùng ông tin các bạn bình
luận đấy các bạn cũng hiểu mà nó ngoại
khi nghe các bạn thấy trân trọng hơn còn
cái bạn nào mà đã không theo ngày công
nghệ không tin thì học với vợ đến loại
mày thì công nhận là mình khẳng định về
các bạn thì nó lùi thật Mình xin lỗi các
bạn nên dừng Ngay từ giây phút mà nhờ
Sanko sao ấy đi
vi phạm ấy thế đúng ạ
nãy giờ mình đánh em mình bảo mình chia
sự nhiều phím tắt cho mình quên mất rồi
chị xem phim bop bình thường hay Gõ đôi
khi là nó sẽ là
cho các bạn biết kiểu dùng phím mũi tên
rồi control không ạ căn chỗ này nó sẽ
nhảy hẳn đã một cái hẳn cái chữ Hằng cái
chữ rộng như thế này
và mình thể cắn trốn ship nhà này để bôi
đen rất nhiều cái nhà này hoa cà
cho mình hệ ấn mình thấy hay Bấm em là
đợi để nhảy đến cuối dòng hoặc cả nút
home để nhớ đến đầu dòng chẳng hạn như
thế này một mình ship xong rồi
Đã ship trong ngày hôm thế này để bôi
đen cả một dòng
ở đây 7 là một trong những cái phím tắt
mà mình thấy anh dùng thì lập trình
Ngoài ra còn những phím tắt gì nữa hôm
trước là mình có cho các bạn làm cái bài
trắc nghiệm vui vui cái dụng Windows D
đấy mà nhảy đền á
à đ.m màn hình destop đây là ai cũng sẽ
hiển thị lại toàn bộ những cái mình ở
mình nằm ở đây có những phím gì nữa thì
ra là các bạn trai nó ra một đống cho
những cái phím của biến nhất mình thường
hay dùng giống như là Windows xong rồi
mũi tên xuống để thu nhỏ màn hình
Windows mũi tên lên mà không to màn hình
à
a Windows sang hai bên như thế này để mà
cho hai màn hình cân xứng nhau này kiểu
như thế này
anh cảm thấy xinh n trí nhớ Nguyễn Thế
thôi
ờ
ờ công có biết được là công dùng card
Zone ship n ở trong ở trong chính cái ạ
nhiều cái khác giống như ạ Windows
Explorer nào
Ừ ông điên mày ông biếc 9 bắt tôi vừa
bấm rồi nó tự động mở Windows explore
expro này là chúng ta nào
ô ô ngoài trả lời được cho 10 luôn à
a cho Tuấn nghiệp luôn cái khóa lại
không ạ
Ừ đúng rồi cần ship n là để tạo folder
nhưng mà ý mình là phím tắt nào để làm ở
được cái Windows Explorer nè
a Windows more đấy các bạn tốt nghiệp
với chúc mừng xe tải KIA thế music mình
tận dụng phím tắt nhiều lắm ý
ví dụ là mình mình mình đã từng nói là
mình bị tịch thu con chuột mà mình phải
sử dụng hết bằng bàn phím nên mình thuộc
hết phím tắt
ví dụ là ff3 thì ra F3 là để tìm kiếm
này không ạ
ông bà hoặc là F6 Vì Ai
ta0 chương trình một máy mẹ sau thanh
xuân L controller để mà nhảy đến cái
ngày đến để mà chỉnh sửa cái cái đường
dẫn này đúng không em
ở thời tiết đêm cạnh F2 ở để mà ghim
hoặc đội đầu cái gì đó
ai ngờ tôi sẽ chỉ chông gai nữa kiến
thức này không ai kiến thức mà cho ông
cần phải biết lắm chứ không biết vụ là
có thể có được thẳng trên này để mà để
đến được một trang web không
à à
Ừ
ông chưa thử vụ này vợ đúng không này
tôi mở trang web bằng bằng gỗ trong
trong cái này đấy
a Windows l khóa màn hình ngoài
ios6 trong Chrome là để trò và sang địa
chỉ nhưng có vẻ mình vừa thử F6 trong
này không được
nhưng mà Win à Nhưng mà controller Thì
nó đều là hình tròn đến hàng nữa chị
Ừ đúng rồi và phím tắt mình hay dùng nữa
nó là Windows ship s mặc nhất đó là để
mà chụp cái đoạn nào đó xong rồi ăn
control V Nó xảy ra rất là ổn ngọt sẽ ra
được cái ảnh luôn đã mình thường skin
skin shop như thế
ở đây để mình xin tắt nhưng mà chắc là
nếu mà đây có khi ai cũng biết biết qua
rồi không ạ
Ừ ok thì
Ừ thì các bạn mình tin là có vài bạn vừa
rồi trả lời nhưng có như bạn thì đấy
kiến thức mới ngon thì các bạn nên tra
Google rộ là họ sẽ SopCast nữa ngon cho
cắt Khi bột à
Đi đâu chị ạ sẽ tổng hợp rất nhiều cái
ở những cái kiểu phím tắt cá thư để mà
mờ cái gì đó giống như là các bạn bây
giờ gần như biết hết về cái cân cái kiểu
để mà nhảy sang Pháp khác như thế này đó
là dùng
em bước đi tôi gõ nhiều quá Tôi còn quên
nó gì Con nó ăn tắt đúng không an tát
nữa chị ạ
cho tôi thấy được ăn nhiều không không
biết nhà ăn tát này để ra bất tiện không
a Window g miniature để chơi game
mà mình từng dùng Minh đau giờ để mà
quay video và thực ra là được nó không
nó không ngon bằng obs
Ừ đúng rồi ông bạn kia vừa nói thêm một
cái mà phím tắt là mình thương ấy rất
dùng này đó là các bạn không ai biết là
căn chôn card w ở động tác nhưng mà khán
chuông w0 những động tác mà đóng được
rất nhiều cái khác
đóng rất nhiều cái khác ví dụ vừa rồi
đóng Windows Explorer này nọ dùng
control ta lưu được
à à
anh không không có phải mỗi mỗi chương
trình duyệt đâu thứ cả ông mà biết rõ
những cái phím tắt ở trên trình duyệt
các bạn sẽ áp dụng được rất nhiều chỗ
khác
Ừ đúng rồi và control + với số nữa để
chuyển Tab mình thì anh dùng mà Thì anh
dùng máy à
Ừ Tự nhiên bây giờ Biến hàng
các video trên tổng hợp các phím tắt
ở đâu để xem
à À vẫn cả thôi bây ở cũng cũng khá lâu
mình xin phép trả lời nó cái câu này nhá
Ừ
ờ ờ
Ừ cái cắt các bạn chạy bình luận ở trên
máy cái cái trên cái
à à
anh kể Trang Te cái bồ này Thực ra là
mình thấy cái nó hơi bị bất tiện một tí
nên là
về đến nhà các bạn cứ cứ trả lời ở đây
mình sẽ trả lời nhưng mà các bạn sẽ thấy
là nó không
à còn câu cuối đi không có ấy xong hết
rồi
ở đâu còn còn ở đó
à à câu này á con này vừa nãy anh đợi
trả lời trên mất rồi nó tương tự mà đi
Ừ thì các bạn trả trả lời hết bài tập
vào đây này mình mình thấy được cái bình
luận nào mình mình trả lời ngay nhưng mà
Ừ nó đúng như cái mà các bạn ăn nhỉ đối
với một thằng ăn mịn nó chỉ nhìn được
như thế này thôi thấy ra đó các bạn mà
trả lời trả lời ở trong bình luận nhà
đưa khi mình phải kéo súng hết Xong hàng
ngày ngày thì phải kiểu vào đây kiểm tra
liên tục nên là đôi khi mình sẽ bỏ lỡ bỏ
lỡ những cái câu hỏi các bạn nên là nếu
mà các bạn thấy mình lâu không trả lời
quá thì các bạn có thể chủ động inbox
mình nhé
thì
các bạn vẫn lên bình luận ở đây thay vì
cứ inbox pin thì ra nó bị Hơi nhiều quá
thật nhưng mà
ơi các bạn hãy thử ca nó rất bất tiện mà
ngon bình luận có bài nó lên đến 4 mấy
luận rồi còn có bình luận trong bình
luận con của bình luận nữa thì mình khó
kiểm soát thật sự rất khó kiểm soát thì
mày ngồi trả lời đúng đấy
nhà mình có phải kéo xuống bởi vì đấy
Dạo này ngày nào mình cũng phải ngồi
lướt kiểm tra kiểm tra sông đồng này xem
có bình luận nó mới không các dự thứ
em nghe là các bạn thông cảm cho mình về
vụ lại có thể là các bạn bình luận rồi
mà mình không để ý bạn nên nhắn tin cho
mình nhá
chúng mình trả lời cho nhiều bạn mình
nghĩ là mình có tâm phát mình trắng lên
các bạn có tấm phết đấy ạ
Ừ rồi nói chung à Hôm nay buổi cuối của
cấp 3
Ừ tí sao mình sẽ lên bài tập sớm sau đó
đi mình sẽ
chỉ bằng một cái bang derma
một
tuần tuần sau
vì
tình lịch lịch học các khóa sau chiến
tranh thế cho bạn nhé
Ừ thôi Xin
chào các bạn mẹ các bạn khóa sau